[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
kim potter's fate now in the hands of
the jury we head to minnesota for the
latest on deliberations and the signals
the jury is sending in the former police
officer's manslaughter trial and was the
jessie smallett investigation mishandled
we take a look at the special
prosecutor's scathing report plus new
information in the pike county massacre
that according to jake wagner
george
did not shoot or kill anybody does that
mean george wagner iv should be spared
the death penalty and later the federal
sex crimes trial of gelane maxwell law
and crime network's adam classfeld is at
the courthouse with the latest on
deliberations law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome to law and crime daily i'm
angenette levy in for brian buckmeyer
and with me in new york is terry austin
we begin with day three of jury
deliberations in the trial of former
police officer
kim potter this is all unfolding in
minnesota potter as you may recall faces
charges of first and second degree
manslaughter stemming from the shooting
death of dante wright during a traffic
stop in april
potter that is and an officer in
training pulled right over for an
expired tag when they determined he had
a warrant for a weapons charge they
attempted to take him into custody body
camera footage shows the struggle and
right trying to take off potter yelled
taser taser taser but shot right in the
chest with her gun wright's car sped
away and crashed and he died the
liberations began on monday and on
tuesday jurors indicated they could be
deadlocked with a question they posed to
the judge
members of the jury use
submitted two questions for me
the first question is if the jury cannot
reach consensus
what is the guidance around how long and
what steps should be taken
and
your answer
the answer is i'm going to re-read to
you an instruction
that i previously gave you
you should discuss the case with one
another and deliberate with the view
toward reaching agreement
if you can do so without violating your
individual judgment
you should decide the case for yourself
but only after you have discussed the
case with your fellow jurors and have
carefully considered their views
you should not hesitate to re-examine
your views and change your opinion if
you become convinced they are erroneous
but you should not surrender your honest
opinion
simply because other jurors disagree
or merely to reach a verdict
and with terry and i today is philip
dube he is a deputy public defender in
los angeles county but he is not here in
his official capacity he is here in his
personal capacity to offer his insight
and his expertise so philip thanks for
joining us i'll start with you
the jurors also asked the judge whether
or not they could see the firearm that
kim potter was carrying without the zip
ties that kept it in the box so
that coupled with the question about not
reaching a concession consensus as a
defense attorney how do you see that
oh i'm smiling uh as to the gun that's a
very serious question that the jury has
and by the way it might just be one or
two jurors that want to know keep in
mind that when kim potter uh approached
dante wright
both of her weapons namely the taser and
the service revolver were resting in a
holster so the only thing she really had
physical access to was the handle so the
jury's probably going to want to see if
she could tell by the field the contours
the design the weight
if somehow the handles of both of those
items could be easily confused as
opposed to seeing them both removed and
looking at the different colors and the
size and the weight but whether or not
the handle uh could
distinguish them in any way
regarding the questions that they had
um regarding unanimity
or what they do if they're deadlocked
you know unanimity is only required to
convict and to acquit it is not required
to hang the jury and if you have one or
two loan holdouts bless their souls from
a defense standpoint
now terry i'm interested in what you
have to say about this you know the jury
asking for guidance if they can't reach
a consensus should the prosecution be
worried
oh the prosecution is definitely worried
because of their deadlock there will be
a mistrial as philip was mentioning
there and i think it would be a loss for
the prosecution they could bring the
charges again but that would take more
time and more resources so i think that
they would probably think twice about
doing that but yeah so far i think the
prosecution needs to be worried
very interesting and it'll be
interesting to see how it all shakes out
we're moving on now to federal court in
california where the fate of elizabeth
holmes a former silicon valley ceo is
also in the hands of a jury on tuesday
jurors asked judge edward davila if they
could take the jury instructions home to
review them judge davila denied that
request saying all deliberations should
take place in the jury room jurors heard
15 weeks of testimony with more than 32
witnesses holmes faces two counts of
conspiracy to commit wire fraud and nine
counts of wire fraud for her time with
the now defunct company theranose once
touted as a company that would
revolutionize blood testing later
testing found that there were many
issues with theranos's edison testing
device if convicted holmes faces the
possibility of 20 years in prison and a
fine of 250 thousand dollars plus
restitution deliberations will resume
thursday
and in wisconsin an accused murderer
stands before a judge weeks ahead of his
trial all this in connection to the
murder of a prominent milwaukee attorney
in september 2020 theodore edgecombe was
riding his bike as jason clearman and
his wife drove nearby edgcomb's defense
team says surveillance video shows the
car tried to run edgecomb off of the
road after clearman got out of the
vehicle edgecomb shot and killed him
edgecombe's attorneys claimed clearman
lunged first and that he was acting in
self-defense
investigators found and arrested
edgecombe in kentucky six months after
the shooting edgecombe is charged with
homicide but claims newly released video
proves he killed clearman in
self-defense law and crime will have
gavel to gavel coverage of that trial
starting january 3rd so tune in to the
network
to follow all of the developments
well still ahead on law and crime daily
a plea from one of the family members
charged in the pike county massacre why
he says the death penalty should be
dropped and what the judge decided
but first a scathing report on the
investigation into jesse smallett's
claims he was the victim of a hate crime
our experts on what it could mean for
the prosecutor that's next on law and
crime daily
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily we
have an update for you on the jesse
smallett case out of illinois and an
investigative report that's come out
that says that the state's attorney's
office in cook county mishandled the
case
earlier this month smollett was found
guilty of felony disorderly conduct for
filing a false police report in an
alleged attack in 2019. prosecutors say
smollett made up the hate crime attack
for publicity this week an investigation
into the cook county state's attorney's
office was released revealing misconduct
by kim fox and her office the report
says the state's attorney's office lied
about several things during the
investigation including smollett's
criminal background after learning the
actor was a suspect in the case fox also
lied about cutting off contact with
smallett's sister
initial charges were dropped against
smallett in 2019 but smallett was later
indicted on new charges after a special
prosecutor was appointed well philip
dube i'm going to start with you on this
one you know what should happen to kim
fox as a result of this investigation
she is the elected official who's
ultimately responsible for all of the
actions taken by her office
criminally nothing should should happen
and jeanette in my humble opinion as the
lead prosecutor for an entire county she
has broad discretion under the
separation of powers to file withdraw
seek to dismiss or or not otherwise uh
pursue charges including the rejection
of charges if the public at large or her
electorate is dissatisfied with any
decision not to pursue charges the
remedy is the next election you vote her
out
and terry i'm wondering what you think
you know the special prosecutor dan
webbs found no evidence of criminal
misconduct but the report was incredibly
you know critical of kim fox so how can
that be reconciled
well on the one hand anjanet the special
prosecutor is saying that there's
nothing criminal here but on the other
hand he is saying that the case was
mishandled he's saying that
maybe there might have been some ethical
breaches she should have been more
forthright she should have communicated
better and before dropping the charges i
think one of the things the special
prosecutor was trying to say is the case
should have been handled more ethically
and more thoroughly so basically her
conversations with the somali family
should not have occurred and it would
have been more advisable perhaps if she
had recused herself only because she
really does know the family so that's so
that they can avoid the appearance of
any sort of conflict but overall there's
nothing criminal here she could have
possibly handled it slightly better but
basically as philip says
they can be voted out if they don't like
uh what happened here so that that
possibility does exist
yeah it'll be definitely interesting to
see what the voters there in cook county
do the next time she's on the ballot all
right coming up next on law and crime
daily the federal sex crimes trial of
gelane maxwell we're going to bring you
the very latest from inside the
courtroom plus the latest on the pike
county massacre will a judge grant
george wagner's request to avoid the
death penalty that's coming up after
this
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back one of four members of a
family accused in the murders of eight
members of another family is asking a
judge to drop aggravated murder charges
against him along with the possibility
of the death penalty george wagner iv is
accused of conspiring with his younger
brother jake and their parents angela
and billy to murder members of the
rhoden and gilley families jake and
angela have admitted to their roles and
have agreed to testify against george
and billy if jake testifies truthfully
the death penalty for his family members
will be taken off the table that's part
of the deal he made with prosecutors
jake wagner admitted to personally
killing five of the victims and shooting
a sixth in april 2016 so he and his
family could have the sole custody of
the daughter he had with hannah rhoden
george's attorneys say the aggravated
murder charges against him should be
dismissed since he didn't shoot anyone
george wagner didn't shoot anybody
yet the state is pursuing death
and what is unique to this case
is that it has taken death off the table
it has agreed to a life plea
for jade
who killed at least five people that's
inherently unfair we made the same offer
to all four co-defendants in this matter
that we would
negotiate with them if in fact
they
not only told us what happened that
night but also
jake wagner led us the physical evidence
he led us to murder weapons that we
never had that was extremely critical to
the resolution of this case
now judge randy dearing denied the
request to dismiss those aggravated
murder charges and the death penalty
specifications wagner's trial is
scheduled to begin in april of next year
and let's bring philip and terry back in
to discuss this philip you're a criminal
defense attorney out there in la but in
ohio just knowing about a crime like
this and being present that means you're
legally culpable but do you think that
his attorneys have a point about the
death penalty
not one point at all unfortunately under
ohio law if you knowingly conspire
even with the gunman and you are the
non-shooter you are liable for the
aggravated murder which is a capital
offense under ohio law and it sounds
like this prosecutor offered all the
co-conspirators a non-death offer but it
sounds like wagner senior is going for
broke because he doesn't want to serve
life in prison
and terry i'm wondering do you think it
made any sense for wagner's attorneys to
file this motion
even though you know jake it's very
clear if he follows through and he
testifies truthfully the death penalty
is off the table for the rest of the
family
well that's a great question anjanet you
know what the defense is doing here is
hedging their bets if jake doesn't
follow through with his profit now his
proffer was the fact that he was the
shooter not george and he has to
basically get on the stand he has to
testify truthfully and the prosecution
has already said that they're willing to
drop the death penalty against everyone
not just jake but george as well and she
said that she offered that deal to
everyone so it's not unconstitutional as
the defense was trying to say so i think
ultimately that the defenses argument
failed here they were trying to go for
broke and that did not work they wanted
the judge to dismiss all of the charges
against them because they're saying that
what the prosecution is doing is unfair
but at the end of the day as you heard
the judge decided ultimately no i'm not
going to dismiss these charges and
basically i think if in fact
jake doesn't testify then the defense
for george could always bring that issue
back up but for now all the charges are
standing against george
that's for sure and it'll be ultimately
up to the jury to decide and one
interesting point you know his attorneys
george's attorneys wanted jake to be in
court to testify at this hearing
to testify that george didn't shoot
anybody and the judge said no way we're
not doing that so um just that was an
interesting little tidbit that came out
of that hearing all right when we come
back we're going to move on to the trial
of gelane maxwell in federal court law
and crimes adam classfeld is going to
bring us a report from the courtroom as
deliberations move forward
welcome back the jury has ended its
deliberations in the federal sex crimes
trial of gelane maxwell for the week
without reaching a verdict those
deliberations will resume after the
holiday weekend now the british
socialite and former girlfriend of
jeffrey epstein pleaded not guilty to
six felony sex crimes charges throughout
the trial the jury heard testimony from
women who say maxwell groomed them for
epstein to sexually abuse epstein was
charged with similar crimes in 2019 but
was found dead by suicide in his jail
cell before his case went to trial the
prosecution's argument focused on
maxwell's connection to epstein
meanwhile the defense told jurors
maxwell is a scapegoat for the former
financier deliberations as i mentioned
will resume next week
and our own adam classfeld has been in
the courtroom the entire time throughout
this federal trial and he's been
bringing us up to date so let's listen
to a little bit of the latest from adam
klesfeld
they are looking for a wide variety of
evidence first right off the gate they
looked for the transcripts of all of
glenn maxwell's alleged victims that
includes jane the first accusing witness
uh annie farmer the only witness who is
testifying against her under her full
and real name
and also carolyn
who is the at the nexus of the sex
trafficking count so they're they wanted
the entire transcripts from them notably
they did not ask for the transcript of
kate because it's already been decided
by judge nathan
that kate was above the age of consent
and can't be considered
to convict glenn maxwell based on the
alleged acts she described so they're
paying attention right off the gate
those three accusing witnesses
the next jury note was very interesting
they asked for notes from an fbi
uh interview with carolyn in 2007. now
here's why that's significant those
notes generally known as 302s are not in
evidence and they are unauthenticated
records of an fbi interview they're not
a transcript and the defense throughout
the case
has told the jury that their stories
have changed and right now the jury is
considering that issue has carolyn's
story changed from 2007
according to the notes of that interview
to
her testimony this year
and that was adam classfeld talking
about the questions the jurors had for
the judge and the evidence they're
looking to see
philip i'll start with you on this one i
spoke with adam and he said the defense
appeared to be very happy after hearing
those questions from the jurors that
they were smiling
should they be this happy should they be
excited about these questions
oh no we don't count our chickens it is
much too premature keep in mind that the
jurors are going through multiple counts
and it could be that maybe they're hung
up on one count
this mac maxwell's exposure is 40 to 50
years so maybe she'll beat one count or
hang one count she's still looking at a
boatload of time it sounds like the jury
wants to see the raw notes from the fbi
agent who interviewed one of the victims
who was put into trafficking years ago
it appears that the contemporaneous
notes taken by that fbi agent are
inconsistent with what the woman is
saying on the stand in front of the jury
juries don't like it they want to see
the raw wet notes that were taken
contemporaneous to that conversation to
that interview with the woman and if
they don't match that's reasonable doubt
really interesting and uh i could get
into a whole another topic about how the
fbi does not record these interviews
with audio or video but i digress that's
a topic for another day i i think they
should be doing that but terry uh we're
getting some late word now that they
have requested the jury actually
requested the transcripts from kate
another one of the accusers so they have
requested now the transcripts from all
four
accusers what do you make of that what's
the significance
wow that's interesting i was going to
say that i thought they didn't ask for
kate because the other three were
younger and as adam mentioned we
shouldn't consider kate really as a
victim because she was 17 at the time
two of them were 14 and one was 16. but
i also think that they weren't going to
ask for kate because she seemed to be
the most credible to me there weren't
that many inconsistencies
she also admitted some things like the
fact that maxwell and epstein did not
like the use of drugs so she never did
drugs around them and that was saying
basically that they were you know good
people they didn't like the use of drugs
so
now that they've called for it i think
they are considering all of the evidence
they want to make sure they know
everything that happened
all right all right well phillip thanks
for joining us today we appreciate it
and thank you for joining us on this
edition of long crane daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you